right now the real problem is the swamp
whether it's just purely the DC swamp or
it's the media Elite corporate press
That's the swamp and Russell and the
governor talked about that as well you
still have people today fauci and the
like they think that what they did was
right they think that these lockdowns
worked and so my fear is if this happens
in the future a lot of these people are
going to want to do the same thing again
so one of the things I pledged as
president and I think I'm the only one
running on the Republican side who will
be willing to do this we're going to
bring a reckoning to this health
bureaucracy and this medical swamp
because these agencies like CDC nihfda
they failed the American people they
become corrupted and they did a lot of
damage with these unscientific
anti-freedom policies well that's pretty
here in retrospect to your stance
increasingly seems to have been the
correct one and that's interesting and
exciting in fact to hear you talk about
a reckoning interesting because if you
listen to my interview with RFK Jr from
a couple weeks ago if you've listened to
virtually anything that RFK Jr who's the
Renegade Democrat right now he sounds an
awful lot like the governor of Florida
the Republican governor of Florida again
there is a lane for all of these people
we got to figure out what that looks
like
[Music]